true hell is when the person you are
meets the person you could have been
Philip Lin had this idea this is from
Douglas Murray who told me about it he
said I felt like I'd been shunted to the
side of my own life often times there's
a thing we must do something we're
called or compelled to do and yet we can
ignore this sense and proceed in a
different direction not take the risk
not try the thing or make the change
this is how we shunt ourselves to the
side of our own lives by ignoring the
things we feel called to do in place of
things our fears rationalize that we
should do instead we can protect
ourselves from failing publicly by
ensuring that we fail privately even
though it doesn't seem it in the face of
a big scary decision the pain of regret
hurts much worse than the pain of
failure George Mack who was telling me
about imagine that you met God at the
Pearly Gates and he said you did all
right why do you just come with me and I
can show you what you were supposed to
do this is the life that you were
supposed to live and it was you taking
the chances it was you having the
conviction to follow your courage and to
go after the things that you truly
wanted it was you playing to win not
playing to not lose